Ami's reality hits storage wars revolves
around the unknown the bizarre and the
surprising all of which lay safely
ensconced within abandoned lockers
despite the plethora of oddball items
there are certain discoveries that were
bound to rise to the surface as
exceptionally noteworthy Barry Weiss who
is known as the collector may not be the
most successful character on the show
but he certainly makes up for it with
his entertaining commentary and
hilariously questionable bidding
decisions all of this was on full
display when Weiss arrived late to an
auction and quickly snapped up what
appeared to be a worthless locker for
inflated $1,525 the wisest seemingly
harebrained a mistake it turns out to be
quite on purpose you can only see
somebody's mouth that's open with teeth
and that's all you can see but I want it
the collector had spotted an interesting
statue in the back and his suspicions
were quickly confirmed this piece got to
be a one-of-a-kind the statue had real
dentures and glass eyes and its head had
been hollowed out to house its own
little scene pictures on the wall
there's a table with the lamp
there's the moon out the window and a
six thousand dollar appraisal a twice
received wasn't enough to tempt us
offbeat tastes and the collector chose
to keep it for his own private
collection buddy I'll see you later
take care Elvis Presley was a king of
rock and roll and there's no doubt that
anything authentically relating to his
life and death is going to carry some
inherent value but it was storage wars
resident bad boy David Hester that
walked away with the Presley mother lode
in season one my curiosity is that
because somebody has these newspapers
wrapped and banded so I'm thinking this
is some type of collectible has to
manage to score a locker filled with
thousands of newspapers featuring Elvis
on the front page
it was the publication date that really
mattered here the vast collection of
periodicals were all dated August 16th
1977 the day Elvis died this is
something that's just going to add up to
hundreds of dollars or thousand
the dollars or even tens of thousands of
dollars I think with such a large
quantity of high valued newspapers has
to knew he had a fortune on his hands
that's proved to be the case when the
vault of rock-and-roll treasures was
valued at a whopping 90 thousand dollars
while storage was than its pin offspring
treasure seekers to a wide variety of
locales they've yet to venture into the
deserts of Asia thus one can imagine the
surprise when the ever eccentric Mary
Padian found a pair of camel saddles in
the locker during the show's eighth
season the antiques became even more
interesting when she took them to be
evaluated by a camel owner
apart from being worth a pretty penny
the rare value balls turned out to be
specifically made for shaggy to hum to
Bactrian camels this species of camel is
native to the rocky deserts of Central
and East Asia and are among the only
truly wild camels are still in existence
[Music]
the storage was crew has seen a lot but
they weren't prepared to encounter the
occult at least that seems to be the
case at judging from brandi passante is
face after she bought a $900 Locker
midway through season 5 that contains
some voodoo paraphernalia I don't know
what this spooky is but I'm not touching
it as Brandi and her team dug their way
down the initial layers of worthless
crap they were surprised to find a small
skull and antlers that immediately
spooked them out like some mad juju
voodoo the supernatural concerns
continued to mount as a voodoo
collection was further unveiled from
trinkets and statues to chicken bones
and beaks the witch dog did stash was
about as unsettling as it gets
this is what the chief holds 20
Virgen check out some of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite stuff are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]